I'm going to get labeled a Marvel fan
boy for this one I know it so this is
just a random ramble on some of the
stuff that Warner Brothers is doing with
DC properties and yeah I'm just going to
open with sort of the punchline on this
I kind of wish that Warner Brothers
would just sell DC to just whoever makes
them an offer I feel like there's their
visit teenagers keeps crashing the car
needs to have the keys to the car take
it away from them before they crash
another one so what is it that got me
into this mode well a couple of things
first of all the flash which so far as I
know has yet to be officially moved off
of its March 2018 date they might want
to do that soon because it's getting a
page-one rewrite in case you're not
familiar with the jargon that goes
around how though what that means that
they are completely throwing out the
script they got starting from scratch
this isn't a dialogue punch up this
isn't uh let's fix actually this is a
starting overall also the film films
have a director that gone through three
I think now now obviously I have no clue
what the problem is with it if I were to
venture a guess though I would say how
consistently popular the flash TV show
is it has to be at least part of the
problem because most of the things you
would want to do with a flash movie at
least as for our story wise goes the
show is kind of being to the punch in
terms of characters who they'd introduce
that's both supporting and villains and
and all this stuff is just if you're
going to be really hard for the movie to
have its own identity oh it can do much
bigger spectacle I can do the only
effects way bigger than the show can
ever do but is it going to be able to
tell a different story but still have it
feel like the flash I have a feeling
that that's the hurdle the thing keeps
running into and honestly I think they
really shot themselves in the foot by
having it be Barry Allen in both I mean
they don't really using solution to this
make the flash in the movies Wally West
it would have removed that
assess 'ti to compare them as much as is
going to end up happening but I mean
that's one thing so what's another thing
they're talking about doing a black Adam
movie before the Shazam movie now from
studio executive logic this makes total
sense because they have the rock and
black Adam why wouldn't you give the
rock his own movie well because he's
playing a character that nobody outside
of the comic book readers know who's
also going to be the villain later
because they talk about doing the
blackout a movie first so you're going
to show us and get it presumably he
would be the protagonist so you're going
to get us on the side of the villain and
then bring in somebody new to beat them
up in up in what would effectively be
the sequel how does that work we're
brothers we should really just take a
quick second and go hmm whatever
happened to that venom movie or the
sinister six movie that Sony was working
on or heck you want more reason history
just look at Suicide Squad yet I know it
made a ton of money I know some people
like it that's great but the overall
reaction was not great even people that
I know who watch and I'm not just
talking about critics I'll talk about
people I know watches the best reaction
I've seen two thing was that was kind of
fun look I didn't want to maximize use
the rock the rock is great he's
charismatic he's lovable and I want to
see him be a villain I'm really
intrigued by that so to see him have a
movie where he's an antihero or whatever
it really you know what it smacks up a
lot is the Scorpion King because the
very personable rock ever appeared in
was The Mummy Returns where he played
the big baddie the score being it well
he played him in a prologue in that it
was a bad CGI recreation and the in the
climax of movie but they then had a
follow-up film telling his backstory and
sort of flesh out this villain and
showing how he got where he was and
joins his humanity and whatever so it's
like they're doing that but they're
doing that one first and then expect us
to root against him in the villain in
the second one I don't think so you know
it made it sound like Geoff Johns was
going to be allowed to steer the
and to try and be something like the
Kevin Feige to DC's like like Kevin
Feige is for Marvel you know the sole
person in charge who you know can keep
things on on point and you have a had
the big picture of mind but these things
that we're hearing these decisions being
made this still sounds like committee
decisions being made by executives
looking at spreadsheets not the choices
made by somebody who knows these
characters now that supposition on my
part I have absolutely no idea what's
going on behind the scenes but I'm just
saying what it feels like and I know
it's not part of the same continuity and
whatnot but I'm going to just vent this
real quick to because it is DC Warner
Brothers related I saw the trailer for
the new animated film coming out Justice
League dark which I can't decide whether
or not I'm excited for and after seeing
the trailer I still can't decide there's
some stuff that I like the whole idea of
normal people having these nightmares
visions that are so real to them that
they then commit horrible acts but
they're doing it in response to these
horrific things that they're seeing that
aren't real that's kind of a cool creepy
cousin I really love the design on the
demons that these people are seeing
that's very cool and then the and the
Justice League showed up and it was a it
was smacking me in the face with the
fact that even though the comics thanks
to rebirth have been able to completely
shut off and then just wriggle out from
under just the weight of everything
wrong with the new 52 that the animated
universe is still using that as their
basis for stuff every time a Justice
League member showed up I'm just yeah
you know what it is it's trying to be
crazy it's like they try to make
everyone Batman and I mean that in terms
of mentality and everyone's like dark
serious and I you know the lines that
they gave to Superman into one room with
a scary face like that old Batman stick
like seriously in terms of the facial
reactions to what was going on the lines
that were said you could put a bat cowl
over Wonder Woman you could have done it
over Superman I would totally bought
that that was Batman saying that line
should not be happening I mean
regardless of what do you think you know
the more golden age or Silver Age
versions of these characters are dorky
or cheesy or whatever they shouldn't
have all the same personality no matter
what it's gonna be
so it's just my sincere hope that with
Justice League dark the Justice League
itself will be shoved into the
background of quickly as possible so
that we can get characters like
Constantine who is fun and swapping who
is awesome plus Zapata and dead man who
are both cool characters with cool
concepts and just let them be like all
the movies like 90% of it please so
there's my little DC Warner Brothers
live-action/animated ramble I'm actually
kind of hard pressed to think of too
much DC related announce stuff that I am
excited about like maybe the Batman
thanks to Ben Affleck's involvement of
that but I'm still going to go see these
things I am because I want them to get
good I will start having faith in these
movies as soon as I get a good one
just something because I'm out of hope I
have no hope left I can't hang hope on
what they've given me and what they've
given me but as soon as there's a good
one I'll be very happy for it and I hope
that's Wonder Woman don't like will be
but in any case that's all that done get
that out of my system so your thoughts
on the current state of DC adaptations
animated live-action rubs on the gun on
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe hit that Bell
down there so you get notifications when
I put new stuff up follow me on twitter
at council geeks check out the council
these podcasts available on itunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
you